youtube va mal cette vidéo n'était pas
du tout prévu à la base mais lui ce qui
se passe en ce moment je me suis dit que
ce n'était pas une si mauvaise idée de
les tenir au courant
il avait raison et youtube veut bien
nous acculer et et j'en paie bien sûr
car en effet youtube a décidé d'eux
nous sommes récemment youtube a changé
son algorithme et quelques bugs ont fait
leur apparition youtube désabonnent
automatiquement les gens de certaines
chaînes youtube
le compteur de vue fait de l'immense
merde et enfin le pire de tous les gens
ne reçoivent plus dans leurs frais
d'abonnement les vidéos des gens
auxquels ils se sont abonnés ça a
entraîné une baisse des vues une baisse
du nombre d'abonnés et une baisse de
motivation la part de tous les créateurs
de contenu mais le vrai sujet de cette
vidéo c'est l'algorithme et tout ce que
ça implique
l'algorithme de youtube c'est quoi c'est
un système qui fonctionne de manière
indépendante est totalement automatique
et qui met en avant des vidéos en se
basant sur certains critères
le watch times à savoir quel pourcentage
de la vidéo le mec qu'a cliquer dessus à
regarder le nombre de pouces bleus et le
nombre de commentaires ça a fonctionné
comme ça pendant des années mais youtube
n'a jamais donné sur quels critères se
basait son algorithme sinon ça n'aurait
plus de sens puisque tout le monde dort
et abusé mais attend des escapades ya
plein mieux qu'ils ont totalement abusé
quand même si tu le congratuler vidéo
promo lui permettre aux six pouces bleus
au début de la vidéo comme bonjour le
ministère de la culture vous entendre
que si cette vidéo vous engagez vous
pouvez cliquer sur le petit bleu il vous
a donné la champagne s'est immolé en
vidéo et ben on va dire delight sur
cette vidéo est à la lumière mais le son
à fond et met un gros like sur ma vidéo
si tu kiffes alors mais un pouce bleu mc
oujda angad
il est le petit poucet bleus bref
algorithmes et tu vas changer maintenant
les vidéos qui sont mises en avant dans
les suggestions sur la page d'accueil
dans l'onglet tendances ne sont plus du
tout la même qu'avant du coup les gens
qui falsifié leurs stats et qui a buzzé
l'algorithme qui avait donc une mine un
en-avant monstrueuse et bat as tu vas
t'en de vue mais c'est [ __ ] je
comprends qu'on puisse s'en vouloir
youtube pour les bucks geste et au début
de la vidéo c'est n'importe quoi et ça
pénalise énormément les petits et moyens
youtuber et c'est ce qu'il faut le moins
pénalisés aujourd'hui qu'un gros
youtuber fassent plus qu'un tiers des vu
qu'il faisait avant c'est pas grave et
gagnent quand même de l'argent il pourra
quand même vivre il continuera quand
même ces vidéos et ça fera toujours pas
mal de vue mais qu'un petit youtuber qui
a déjà un peu ric rac et même niveau
motivation il attend que sa chaîne
prenne de l'ampleur et avance et on lui
met des bâtons dans les roues comme ça
ça c'est dégueulasse ma question est la
suivante peut-on vraiment vouloir à
youtube d'avoir modifié son algorithme
non et non les gars chez youtube ils
sont pas dupes les ont vus tout le monde
arrivait à comprendre les algorithmes et
al manipuler comme ce très cher ibra tv
et ses poses blocs qui sont devenus sa
marque de fabrique moi je suis l'enfant
de pop aux bleus et bottes bleues roses
bleues
je crois qu'il le faudra mettre cent
mille pouces bleus c'est normal de
donner un objectif de pouce bleus à
chacune de ces [ __ ] de vidéos c'est
un truc que tu fais quand tu sors un
gros projet ou quand tu fais très peu de
vidéos antoine daniel pourrait le faire
quand c'est un événement quand c'est un
truc qui change qui voilà que sur lequel
tu as bossé à mort là ok mais demandez
des [ __ ] de pouce bleus en début de
vidéo c'est comme juge et une pomme
avant de la voir manger tu dis pas ici
pour toi il faut au moins été croqué la
pomme donc devant une vidéo il faut au
moins été regardé un bout de la vidéo
c'est bien vouloir soutenir les
créateurs que l'on tire mais le système
de pouce bleus il est là pour dire si tu
aimes bien ou pas une vidéo c'est juste
des coups de battements ce que youtube
heures tu dis que tu te fais pas ton
propre avis sur la vidéo sacra ça pue du
cul du coup on sait pas trop sur quoi de
mal gré de ce base mais tout on a
remarqué que plus une vidéo fait un
temps record de pouce blanc peu de temps
plus elle va être en avant elle va se
trouver dans les tendances un jab avoir
des gens chialent sur les eaux sociaux
youtube moeurs et la fin de you tube bla
bla bla et y en a plein qui dit ça pour
les bonnes raisons qui sont les bugs
mais doutent qu'ils parlent que
d'algorithmes et qui flippe à ce qu'ils
valent en nombre de vues baissé mais
franchement aujourd'hui on se concentre
plus sur est ce que ma vidéo à un bon
petit une bonne nature et surtout est-ce
qu'elle a beaucoup de pouce bleus est ce
que les gens vont mettre beaucoup de
commentaires faut que ce soit un moyen
qu'ils le fassent comme ça elle est mise
en avant et je fais des vues ça fait
combien d'années qu'un mec ne s'est pas
posé la question est ce que ma vidéo
elle est bien c'est vous ou pas ça fait
combien d'années qu'un mec s'est pas dit
ça c'est la base quand même c'est faire
des vidéos qui sont bien trouver le
meilleur moyen de faire des vidéos cool
qui plaisent et qui nous plaisent à nous
les créateurs aujourd'hui plein de gens
râlent parce qu'il voit des trucs 2
aird mise en avant des vidéos pas drôle
pas cool nul mais les amis ceux qui
mettent leurs bons pouces bleus en début
de vidéo avant même d'avoir regardé et
contribue à sa ceux qui écoutent leur
idole qui leur 10ème la vidéo vous
contribuez à cette merde [ __ ] je me
savais comme david lafarge et siph
annoncé à pas du tout et ouais un
véritable héros merci de m'avoir montré
l'exemple à ne pas suivre les gars merci
donc les youtuber plus petits qui n'ont
pas les millions d'abonnés mais qu'il
faut quand même débat mal de vue parce
que faut pas oublier que la cinquante
mille cent mille vu ses énormes [ __ ]
on l'oubli parce qu'on pense qu aux
millions de vu un truc même moi des fois
une vidéo avait fait un million de vues
je fais au el habib et mais ferme-la
gamin faut arrêter de chialer aussi
[ __ ] bref j'ai pas de morale ou de
leçons à donner à fin de cette vidéo et
brad est bien sorti nouvelle vidéo
attendait alors le but c'est de faire un
million d'abonnés en plus en 24 heures
si vous faites ça je vais supprimer ma
chaîne je vais faire un dernier et
vidéos dans lesquelles je sais la
première fois de ma vie que je vois
youtuber plus se fout de votre gueule
que des hommes politiques mon gars ce
qui est drôle c'est que ce gars est le
gars le moins pénalisés par les
politiques youtube
au contraire c'est celui qui a le plus
bénéficié du changement d'algorithme est
celui qui me prendre les mesures les
plus drastiques pour montrer youtube
qu'il est pas content bon honnêtement
que personne n'ya cru et nourri ces
conneries
oh
[Musique]
bref je te blâme pas ibra tv tu as tes
raisons que la raison ignore franchement
un moment il faut arrêter les conneries
venez on fait tout juste des vidéos on
essaie de faire des bonnes vidéos pour
les gens qui sont sur la plateforme ok
on arrête de gueuler ils ont vu qu'on a
gueulé juste plus ni pai pippa number
one au monde fait tout un coup de gueule
autour de ça ils ont vu mais je
comprends que tu perçois pas content
mais il faut pas en venir à faire
n'importe quoi et à ramper à terre pour
être mis en avant par l'égoïsme de
youtube en fait actuellement
l'algorithme a changé et tout le monde
cherche comment faire et sur quoi il se
base pour qu'ils nous mettent en avant
mais les gars la réponse est toute bête
fait des bonnes vidéos au revoir